I am 1 trans woman and now
Thanks to Irene Montero
may be legally registered as such
without the need for hydration
surgery psychological analysis
in fact,
I don't even need to change my name.
and there is not a single type of mechanism
to investigate whether what I say is true
or not because that would be medical
lizard and pathologizing trans reality
the only criterion there is
is that I perceive myself as a woman
and I do it and in addition to that
the almost 500 laws that privilege women in spain
among them the lady or gen
will affect me beneficially
all tax reductions
extensions,
subsidies,
quotas
if you are like me
you have nothing more to ask for
time in the civil registry and there to say
you are a woman and sign
spain is one of the countries of the world
that most discriminates against men
and now with the trans law
there is no need for a single man left
throughout the country
if everyone perceived themselves as women
there would be complete equality before the law
so
if you are starting to perceive yourself as a woman
do not hesitate to go to the registry
which will also not be investigated or anything else